all right now president sippy cup joe
biden today
he had one of his most bizarre moments
yet after he devolved into a
creepy whispering voice when asked about
covet relief spending
honestly you can't make this stuff up
this actually happened
yep this is the president of the united
states
of america you decide employers can't
find workers
i said yeah pay them more
this is an employee's
employee's bargaining chip now
what's happening i got them
1.9 trillion dollars relief so far
they're going to be getting checks in
the mail that are consequential
this week for child care the bill
on the environment why would i not be
for it
i have a question you think it's moments
like this that maybe
force his staff to yell at him and he
gets in big trouble if he ever
answers a question well get this somehow
biden managed to even top that
claiming that quote latin
x latinx people you know don't want to
get vaccinated
because they're scared of being deported
you figure it out it's awful hard
as well to get latinx
vaccinated as well why they're worried
that they'll be
vaccinated and deported i assume you
mean
latino joe but why do you assume
that people that happen to be hispanic
uh or latino or illegal immigrants or do
you have any idea what message you're
even trying to send to the rest of the
world with that bizarre behavior
uh like you know we've seen from you day
after day
you know i thought it was bad enough for
the g7 here's a small sampling
let's just look at your president oh
this is only the last two weeks
take a look i'm leaving out a lot of
people here i apologize i'm to get in
trouble but
anyway we'll get back to that but um
uh we um uh
you know there's a lot that uh
that is is is happening
police chief murray of the baltimore
excuse me
police chief mayor police chief
murphy paul of baton rouge louisiana
we hold the true self-evident that all
men and women
we haven't lived up to completely but
we've always widened
the ark of commitment and included more
and more people
those who say the blood of the the blood
of patriots you know
and all the stuff about how we're going
to have to move against the government
well the tree of liberty is not water
with the blood of patriots what's
happened is
that there are never been if you wanted
to think you need to
have weapons to take on the government
you need f-15s and maybe some
nuclear weapons vladimir putin laughed
at the suggestion that you had called
him a killer
is that still your belief sir that he is
a killer
answer the first question i'm laughing
too
and mayor daniel and mayor daniella
levine cava of miami-dade
and the crickets two one thousand all
right here with reaction
the host of unfiltered i couldn't
imagine a show called filtered
with danbot can you imagine filter dan
mangino anyway right here on the fox
news channel a
great hit right out of the box uh our
friend dan bongino
you know some of this sometimes i'll
admit i laugh
it's funny you know i watched him over
at the g7
and he said well asked a question you
called
uh a putin a killer you still call him
that
um
yeah i don't think it's funny anymore
dan it's actually scary
yeah yeah i mean uh can you really
believe this guy is president of the
united states i mean
we have reverend kane from poltergeist
too
who's the president remember that guy is
your mommy i mean that's what we have as
a prayer
what's with the creepy whispering by the
way is this like one of those like
asthma things or something like what is
going on what is he doing
he's like i paid them the checks it's
it's so creepy like you watch it and
it's like you want to cringe you don't
know if you should turn it off
or turn it up and here's another thing
he lies
like he lies all the time and he lies
about everything
i mean he said during the meeting common
sense kind of stuff he says like
i told them pay more oh thanks joe now
we all figured it out
so restaurants who can't find workers
nobody thought of that before joe
biden said if we just would have paid
him more like clearly he hasn't thought
through that the restaurants can't pay
workers more because they don't have any
money to pay him more
because they don't have workers in the
first place to make any money to pay
workers more
because workers are being paid to sit at
home by joe biden
but again reverend kane uh he didn't
really think of that he's thought of
that through
and he said another thing too he said
that it's a lie that the top
cities for crime are run by democrats
well what is he saying the fbi's lying
just look at the fbi
statistics that's kind of obvious you
know the question
is and what worries me the most about
this
is you know first of all there was a
reason he was hiding
in his basement bunker okay and i called
it the
the media mob big tech uh candidate
protection program now it's the
presidential protection program
same people obviously he's really
struggling with public appearances
obviously they're minimizing his
schedule as much as possible
averaging less than one event a day dan
the question is
yeah you know vladimir putin sees it
they're not influenced by the media in
this country
they they make their own assessments uh
president xi is making
his own assessment the iranian muellers
kim jong-un radical islamic terrorist
groups are making their own assessments
that is the really scary part where does
this
end yeah i mean sean think about it
china right now is making a move on hong
kong
uh they're implicitly and explicitly
threatening taiwan as well
you know like you said part of this you
kind of laugh at but it's really not
funny i mean it really isn't i mean we
have a guy in the white house right now
who by any objective measure it's not
listen i'm a conservative i obviously
don't like joe biden's policies
but i'm really not trying to make this
personal here by any objective measure a
measure demand is clearly compromised i
mean again i i i'm not
diagnosing him i did my graduate work in
psychology but i'm not pretending to be
i didn't stay at holiday inn express
last night you don't need to be a
trained psychologist or psychiatrist
to see there's something wrong and it
really makes you wonder right sean like
why isn't anyone else at the left side
of the of the mainstream media
why aren't they concerned about it as
you said this is the man who controls
the nuclear codes
we have two nuclear-powered enemies
right now led by tyrant killers
xi jinping and vladimir putin and no one
seems concerned about this but
fox news i mean listen this is a serious
issue again the man has his finger
on the tip of the nuclear codes of the
united states with two hostile enemies
you think there'd be a greater level of
concern but there isn't they don't care
all right dan bongino thank you
appreciate it and show every weekend
right here on the fox news channel